الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قالت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت سته
عشره مسيره خلال هجوم روسيا على جنوب شرقي
البلاد الليله الماضيه كما قالت الهيئه ان
قواتها تصدت لمحاولات تقدم روسيه على
محاور كوبيانسك في مقاطعه
ومريمكا في مقاطعه وكشفت الاركان
الاوكرانيه في بيان ان القوات الروسيه
حاولت منع تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه
عبر غارات جويه في مناطق عده في
المقاطعتين
بان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت مساء الخميس
ثلاثه مسيرات اوكرانيه في المقاطعه واوضح
المسؤول ان المسيرات رصدت ودمرت على بعد
كيلومترات قليله من المدينه الواقعه جنوب
غربي روسيا وقد اكد الحاكم ان اسقاط
المسيرات لم يسفر عن اي اضرار او اصابات
افادت خدمه الطوارئ الروسيه عن سقوط مسيره
اوكرانيه في منطقه
كورتشاتوف على بعد كيلومترات قليله من
محطه الطاقه النوويه في مقاطعه كورسك
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا وكان حاكم المقاطعه
اشار الى ان الهجوم الحق اضرارا طفيفه
باحد المباني ومن جهته اكد الرئيس
التنفيذي لوكاله الطاقه النوويه الروسيه
ان الوضع في محطه كورس كان نوويه تحت
السيطره مشيرا الى انه تم اتخاذه جميع
الاجراءات لضمان سلامه محطات الطاقه
النوويه الروسيه
في روسيا ايضا قال موقع ريبار العسكري
الروسيه ان القوات الروسيه تواصل توسيع
نطاق سيطرتها على محور باخموت الجنوبي
اضافه لمحور زفاتوفو بمقاطعه لوجان وافاد
الموقع بان القوات الروسيه تقدمت في بلده
نوفيسيوسكو هي القريبه من حدود مقاطعه
خاركيف خلال هجومته على مواقع الجيش
الاوكراني
وفي مدينه
المتاخمه لدونيسكا ذكر الموقع الروسي ان
القوات الاوكرانيه شنت هجمات على مواقع
الجيش الروسي في بلدتين قريبتين من
المدينه
قال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان العامه في
اوكرانيا عند ريكوبالي في ان قوات بلاده
حققت تقدما في محيط مدينه باخموت بمقاطعه
دونيتسك الشرقيه اوكرانيا واضاف كفاليف ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تصدت جميع محاولات
التقدم التي نفذتها القوات الروسيه في
مقاطاعتي خركيز
يواصل الجيش الاوكراني وعملياته الهجوميه
في اتجاهات
وقد حققت قوتنا المسلحه نجاحات وتعمل على
تعزيز مواقعها وتواصل عمليات القصف
المدفعي والصاروخي للاهداف المعاديه كما
تشن قوتنا المسلحه هجوما شمال وجنوب مدينه
بخمه حيث حققت نجاحات وتثبت قواعدها
القوات الروسيه هاجمت
مناطقيفكا ومارينكا وتمكنت قواتنا المسلحه
من صد كل الهجمات
الينا من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه اللواء فايز الدويري لواء
فايز عندما تقول واشنطن ان الرئيس الروسي
خسر الحرب مع تطورات المعارك هل من مؤشر
يؤكد او ينفي هذا الكلام
يعني لا هو كلام مرسل حتى هذه اللحظه لان
اوراق اللعبه لم تكتمل بعد
والتداعيات القادمه غير معروفه
وارتفاع وتيره استخدام الاسلحه المتطوره
لا تزال جمل مفتوحه لكن هو تقييم للواقع
الحالي ينطلق من القدرات الاوكرانيه على
ادامه الحرب لمده تزيد عن عام ونصف فيما
كانت المراهنه على عشره ايام في بدايه
الحرب
تماسك دول الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي خاصه
بعد الاجتماعات في ليتوانيا والتي وضعت
اطارا لا اقول زمنيا واضحا ولكن اطار واضح
ان اوكرانيا عاجلا ام عاجلا ستصبح جزء من
حلف الناتو وان هناك التزام قادم لسنوات
لضمان الانتصار يقابل
النوع من التصدعات ولم يتم التحقق منها
منذ حركه فاغنر وبريجوجل واختفاء
الجنرال مساعد قائد العمليات وظهور جنرال
اخر ينتقد القياده واقصائه عن عمله اذا
دعيني اقول ان هناك اشارات بان لا يوجد
توافق كامل في الدوائر المحيطه بالرئيس
الروسي وهذا يضعف سيطرته وتمسكه بكافه
اوراق اللعبه يقابله ارتقاء نوعي في
التكاتف والتلاحم الغربي خلف اوكرانيا هذه
المعادله تقرع على انها تسير لصالح
اوكرانيا وان روسيا لن تتمكن من تحقيق
اهداف العمليه العسكريه الخاصه الان هناك
اعلان عن تسليم قنابل عنقوديه هل يمكن ان
يؤثر هذا في المعركه
يعني الان حسب طريقه استخدامها لماذا
تستخدم هي اصلا تستخدم في الحاله
الاوكرانيه الحاليه لتحقيق
امرين الامر الاول التعثر في الهجوم
المضاد ناشئ عن حقول الالغام وعن الخطه
الدفاعيه هذه القنابل باعداد اقل تقدم
خدمات اكبر من استخدام الهيمرز او استخدام
مدافع 155 كما انه يمكن استخدامها لفتح
ثغرات في حقول الالغام وبالتالي هي تسهل
من امكانيه التسريع في شن الهجوم المضاد
الرئيسي اذا ما اعتمدنا التصريحات
الاوكرانيه ان ما يجري الان هو المرحله
التمهيديه اذا هي عمليه يتم احتياجها
لتنفيذ تحركات تعبويه تخدم في التالي
التطورات العملياتيه والاستراتيجيه شكرا
جزيلا من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز الدويري